there were protests at a school in
fairfax
last week
over an alleged racist attack against a
muslim student that happened here's the
cbs affiliate talking about it
an estimated 350 students protested at
fairfax high after they say a student
was attacked here tuesday afternoon
because she's muslim she couldn't
breathe she was laid on the floor she
couldn't move out of her position
students accused the school system of
trying to sweep the instant under the
rug the school's trying to cover it up
instead i had a panic attack which that
did not happen ekron mohammed says some
students made racist drawings in a
marketing class became increasingly
aggressive and then one of them
assaulted her my backpack bumped into
him and then he got mad and he pushed me
and he grabbed my hijab mohammed says he
pulled her hijab off and when she fought
back he shoved her hard into a desk
everybody was outside waiting for the
buses and we saw the ambulance come into
the school physically my whole left side
of my body is bruised
mentally i'm okay because i have all the
support around me today muhammad says
she and the student were given the same
punishment a one one-day in-school
suspension which they served wednesday
in the same room where she says the
student kept looking at her that's
entirely unacceptable and that's
something i want to go back to see with
staff how we can do better in the future
county school board member abrar omash
the only elected official in virginia
who wears a hijab says she's concerned
by the response the school system told
us it is investigating and quote no
further details can be shared at this
stage as administrators work to
establish the facts fairfax county
public schools and city of fairfax
schools support the rights of students
to peacefully protest
so there they are protesting over this
uh this hate crime and well we heard
it's a hate crime there were racial
slurs that were used
this anti-muslim hate crime and all that
so now we get to the twist ending that
i'm sure you saw coming
from a million miles away this is from
wtop this is a city of fairfax police
department investigation has determined
that a physical altercation at fairfax
high school on tuesday was not a hate
crime according to a press release the
investigation revealed there were no
racial comments made by either student
according to police police said that the
female student confirmed her hijab
became partially undone during the
altercation exposing her hair the female
student told police that the information
posted on several social media sites
stating that racial comments were used
during altercation were false
uh not just on social media sites but as
you as you heard the media itself has
been reporting this
nonetheless hundreds of students from
fairfax high school in virginia walked
out in protest on thursday showing their
support
for a student they say was attacked in
an islamaphobic incident
the student herself is saying that's not
what happened well she's saying that now
i think initially that that's where they
got this story but very quickly she
backed away she said there were no
racial slurs used this what here's what
it was it was a a fight that she got
into
a mutual fight as happens in high
schools uh with another student the
other student by the way not white
so these were two non-white students who
got into a fight
and during the fight her you know her
headdress
was was partially dislodged and it
showed a little bit of her hair
and then this story
arises
now i don't i don't know what motivated
her to come up with this version of the
story
it's not hard to come up with some
theories
maybe one of them is she didn't want to
get in trouble for being in a fight so
she so she came up with the hate crime
story instead
it seemed like a pretty
logical assumption here i don't know if
that's true or not who knows
who knows what motivates these people to
invent these kinds of stories
but we know we know generally speaking
what motivates it is that
is that she's growing growing up in a
world and she looks around and she sees
that
you know victimhood pays
victimhood gives you some points you can
cash them in you can cash in those those
tokens
in a lot of different ways and benefit
from it
get yourself out of a tight spot it's
kind of like a get out of jail free card
maybe get out of suspension free card
here
but if you're a rational person even i i
saw this story a couple a few days ago
when they were first walking out over
this
anti-alleged islamophobic hate crime
as as soon as i saw it my first reaction
was yeah that probably didn't happen
because yet again this is this is a it's
actually it's good news
it should be good news
that this sort of thing just isn't
happening
it's it's simply not happening in the
country
you're not going into a modern high
school in modern america and there are
white students tearing the hijabs off of
uh off of muslim girls and shouting
islamic phobic slurs at them that's not
happening
we could celebrate that because that's
that's a great thing that those these
sorts of events aren't happening
[Music]
uh unless
you know
unless victimhood is what you crave in
which case you see that as a bad thing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated